good morning Millennials welcome to the
morning toast one hour later happy
Thursday thank you for shucking and
jiving with us I'm loving this one hour
later feels like daylight savings thank
you everyone for pushing back an hour I
just I needed the extra hour I'm so
paranoid about losing my voice and when
I do a lot of shows I tend to lose my
voice and especially when I don't sleep
so I went to bed last night I got home I
literally was in bed by 9:45 slept and
needed the extra hour this morning I'm
back to back two nights in a row
sleeping 12 hours I just like have a big
show in Inglewood tonight big show it's
on Saturday at the Beacon cannot lose my
voice that's why I'm drinking tea and we
are happy to accommodate
we at the morning toasts are always
happy to sleep in for you Joe
commentating Brown ya know like I'm
happy to sleep in whenever you need me
to so like if you're not feeling hundred
percent let me know I will sleep in
thank you sis you are you're so
considerate I don't know what I would do
without you any time also last night I
too got in bed like around 9:45 and then
I finished my book finally and it was so
fantastic I can't recommend it enough
it's called I am pilgrim and like I've
been it was a really long book it's 800
pages I saw it on Kindle you don't know
how long things are cuz it just shows
you percentages umm and so I've been
reading it like the past few days in the
payoff like was it was there it was it
was so not what I would have expected
for myself the kind of book that I would
enjoy but it's really got me thinking
you know well i rewatch my show this
show and i find that every time you
started talking about books like my and
I definitely apologize because it's
something you're passionate about and
like I just don't care no I'm not fit
here's the thing usually if you didn't
care like I probably wouldn't continue
to bring it up but I get so many
questions about what books I'm reading
great books suggestions and I like I've
said I found that it's been so good for
my mental health educator the minds of
America yeah I'm just like being a like
judgey over here I just apologize for
not care and I was just like thinking
like maybe I start like a book club
podcast like this could my this is my
passion honestly like you have your
tiene and Instagram and I'm so happy for
you know that I am maybe should like
write a book oh for sure what why I'm
Jackee
was I'm like reading books I'm like you
know I can actually probably write a
book but then Jake so hearts write about
what would I write about would I write
fiction or nonfiction would I write
about myself or would I I would kind of
want to write like a why a novel that's
loosely based on my life but like more
drama yeah I mean speaking of Y I just
watched the trailer for to all the boys
I love before - because it
underrated Lee comes out in two weeks
and it looks so good and I'm like loving
the whole like new large gene and and
the John Ambrose of it all but it seems
like she really gets caught up in this
love triangle and I just can't imagine
ever being caught up and like shouting
no a centennial no and that's the
problem with sequels because the end of
the first movie movie you always get the
love story but then the sequel will have
throws a wrench it has to up end it so
um but I look forward to it and Jordan
Fisher who plays John Ambrose is a cutie
he looks like he does a good job but
it's just like stop like we have the
perfect couple over here I don't know
maybe I'll go to the other side and it
doesn't see he doesn't come in as a
villain so it's really like who does she
choose oh my god it looks really good
dude I like I wanted no spoilers if you
read the book I don't want to know yeah
I won't read the book because I'm done
reading about people in high school
that's where I draw the line no honestly
that's all I can read about I just love
high school you'll read it I mean maybe
I could still read The Clique books cuz
like I have a soft spot for a greater
Nick cuz I was soft but spot for 7th
graders but um no I can't read about
like teenagers in high school I just I
can't I think we should both talk about
we kind of had big nights we kind of had
big nights I think yours with like
bigger so I don't agree really Jackie
got and and met finally and took a pic
with Tyler see ya know I met Tyler see
we were both at this event for T vs the
second season of miracle workers and we
like have the same agents so it was easy
right mutual friend - so we've been
meaning to meet him
yeah and the agent and the mutual friend
were all there so like it was just you
know a conversation amongst friends and
I just want to say like he is the nicest
person uh-huh um it was so nice to meet
him and he's also really smart he went
to Wake Forest do you know that no no
better than Colgate and he has his MBA
was fun fact they told me that was my
material I guess tell you guys that on
the matter I didn't want to sees him but
like that seems like information you
need to know how pertinent how did that
come about in conversation because he
was with his friends and I was like how
do you guys know each other and he was
like we went to college together I was
like where'd you go to college they were
like Wake Forest then I was like what
year did you guys graduate blah blah
blah and then he was saying that he got
his MBA
oMG Tyler the scholar yeah and I had to
inquire like he wasn't just someone
throwing it around the information yeah
I understand he wasn't carrying his
degree yeah today he was not too bad
yeah that's so exciting I'm jealous of
the pick you out I have met Tyler see
one time at polar bar and he was having
dinner with the foster sisters which I
found to be really interesting
peirong yeah I think they're just
friends no he's really just a man about
town I was thinking it must be so crazy
to be him and just like walk down the
street and he everybody knows who he is
and like everybody wants to date him
he's the most eligible bachelor in
America right and he wasn't the bachelor
which is so funny right but like the
bachelor Peter is not an eligible
bachelor because he's probably in a
relationship right now right
Tyler is like America's Sweetheart I
agree it must be just like so crazy and
overwhelming to be him like I'm sure
every single person in the room last
night like knew who he was like looking
talking you got him he's just such like
a phenomenon no he's a presence too cuz
he's so big he's so tall been met him he
was like who was that on my Tyler see
those he played football I'm like no
he's just huge yeah so it was really
nice his friends were really nice and
was a really cool party it was like
medieval themed it was crazy like they
had like huge like chicken legs did yeah
it was wild it's so excited it was a fun
party and um dylan sprouse was there cuz
you know how he has his al company oh
yeah so the al company like was a
partner in the medieval themed party
he's such an interesting guy do us proud
yes and he was with her Barbara cuz he
would think like he would be so
obviously falling short to Cole Sprouse
who's obviously on this hit TV show in
this relationship
but honestly I think iced and dylan
sprouse more than cold because of his
relationship with Barbara Palvin
ya know they have really gotten down
their own paths but they seem both so
happy and there's nothing like the look
of happiness and something about like
dylan sprouse for choosing Barbara
Palvin like makes me think he's like
smart do you know what I mean like he
chose Barbara like she is a real woman
yeah I mean I totally agree it's like
who you choose to mate with says a lot
about you as a person hundred percent
and I just think like Barbara is saying
really good things about Dylan I agree
it's good stuff okay I want to hear
about your and Ikes hey we only had so
much fun that I could you know what I
don't wanna like it was great like it
was really it was truly a homecoming to
be back at Caroline's I was having crazy
deja vu and the stage was just like so
small it's like I hate to be so
pretentious but like I haven't played a
comedy club and so long because I've
been doing acts there was stage once
like I really forgot about the
dimensions and everyone was so close to
me and you know in the theatre I
whenever I do sound check I always ask
that the lights are out on the floor
because I don't like to see people's
face it freaks me out I don't wanna see
someone I know but in the comedy club
it's very well lit people are serving
and there's a lot of action actually can
be very distracting and I found it to be
a lot harder to perform but it was
really good practice for me I think I
was really glad that I did it because it
was cool to be back to Caroline's
cool to see so many OG toasters and
there's a point in the show whenever I
say like is this anyone's first time at
a dirty jeans show and like everyone
raises their hand and literally six
people raised their hand it was like I'm
sure all of the oh geez encore encore
that's really nice and just a funny
story is you know the toaster Jamie Cara
yes she's coming she's coming she was at
cam toast and she's coming to camp toast
and I saw her in the audience and she
was with what I thought was her
boyfriend but it ended up being her dad
but I was really far away so if her dad
was kind of cute honestly and because
the the room was so well lit I'm not
used to seeing faces and I was looking
around and I saw her dad and I thought
it was my friend Josh his dad they
looked just like each other and Josh's
dad haven't seen the mayor of angle one
so he's like a really prestigious guy
I'm like why the [ __ ] is he i'ma show
like I was freaking out and I had like
app in my stomach the whole time and I
get offstage Almighty Jacquizz see like
a wilds and they're like no I'm like he
was hitting me right in front of you
live in she goes that was Jamie Karen's
dad that's so funny and then Jamie Cara
posted in the toast service about how
she want to bring you her dad and that
her dad had the best time that he was in
tears that is such of a compliment a
compliment and a vote of approval when
you know someone who's obviously not a
toaster and not a millennial either
coming to the show and not a woman right
having a great time Margaret was like
the guy in front of me talking about her
dad was dying like taking off his
glasses wiping his tears I'm like
Margaret I literally don't believe you
this is the one about Jamie Karen and
then Jamie Cara posted in the Facebook
group that her dad had the best time and
like it was so flattering and I know
that like I care about everyone's
opinion but I really care about the
opinion of like straight men more
because it's not my audience you know
you have to work harder to entertain
that totally there was actually a lot of
straight dudes in the audience last
night just like a lot of toasters
bringing their boyfriends husbands
brothers whatever and it was great and I
had a really great time and thanks to
everyone for coming it was it was good
stuff it's so fun I had such home I feel
like I I don't I feel like I'm always
around you know I don't really miss
stuff you're very supportive and
everyone and I try and like go to
everything and it really I really I
almost came towards the end of the show
like I was like that's pathetic
no it's pathetic that I can't like miss
something yeah you know yeah
I can't let my FOMO like make me sit in
traffic all the way to Times Square
coming up Downing Street oh the yeah
it's pathetic he worked hard at that
party I did she really did um so yeah
that was great
tonight we got and go with New Jersey I
think there's like seven seats left if
anyone wants to go to girls on job Tom
I'm really excited I'm heard of rumoured
that I might be getting a key to the
city of Englewood I heard that and I
heard I mean I answered the email and I
am getting a key to the city which is a
very underrated li-like underwhelming do
you call Mexico key and what is it
unlock really is there a gate to the
city like how there's the same big house
there's doors on the Midtown Tunnel
I said who gets a key to the Midtown
Tunnel that's what I want true cuz
that's like that seems like a doomsday
thing I'll let you know you'll be there
so I'll let you know if I get it I'll be
there for the key yeah Oh what time are
you getting there later because I have a
three hour dentist appointment today
like the shows at 8:00 so what time oh
um hopefully around 7:00 okay you'll be
there for that okay I will let you I
will keep you guys posted on whether or
not it's a physical key I'm at
affordable key or a quiche I don't have
a say I say - okay well I feel like it's
time we have a really busy day today I
got to Inglewood and we've got much to
discuss so without further ado it is
time for the fast five stories that you
need to know yeah you before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast that's true
I don't want to you know I don't want to
embarrass you on your own show by saying
that it's not time when you already said
it thank you embarrass me on your
tick-tock oh please go check out my
tick-tock girl with the tick-tock
tick-tock girl the job would do the
great tick-tock with Jackie before the
show started she's expense and it's just
I don't wanna embarrass you but I do
need to let you know that today's
episode is brought to you by hash tags
bonk on vistaprint
the most important time is now the
importance of feeling professional
polished and prepared when it counts is
right now and for small-business owners
or people who produce her own podcasts
for their own empires like us being
plugged in and prepared when an
opportunity comes up is crucial those
moments happen all the time they're
happening right now and having a
business card that shows how
professional you are in your pocket
ready to hand out is the first step to
making something happen your next big
opportunities come in and we're here to
help you own a now with free shipping on
any business card in any quantity choose
whatever style finish or paper you like
and get free shipping
and because you can pick the colors
fonts designs and images and
you can create something as unique and
compelling as your business plug in your
information and logo into hundreds of
fresh designs tailored to your type of
company or upload your own design if
you're feeling brave pick the paper
stock style and quantity that's right
for you
you can even upgrade to unique touch
like rounded corners
order and receive your cards with free
economy shipping and if you need any
more reason to choose Vistaprint you can
feel good knowing that they use only
carefully selected inks and responsibly
sourced paper stocks your satisfaction
is 100% guaranteed or your money back
they'll make it right this sprint wants
you to be able to own the now in any
situation which is why our listeners
will get free shipping on all business
cards any style any quantity just go to
vistaprint.com enter the promo code
toast for free shipping on all business
cards any style any quantity it's a
limited time offer so make sure to own
the now at vistaprint.com promo code
toast sign on the [ __ ] before I
get into the first story one you're not
getting pulled over and two we didn't
talk about Kim and Kylie's make a video
yesterday and everyone's dying to hear
our take on it so let's just get right
into it okay I have one word blush so
much blush that's what I thought you're
gonna get Kim never wears blush or Kylie
put weight on of the wrong shade kylie
is obsessed with blushes she's a her
favorite skin yeah so that's a fair skin
thing to do like the makeup turned out
to be like a little clowny yes her neck
yeah and the cut of the contour and the
ball of the blush like the blush it was
a joker it was like not the best I've
ever seen but I loved the video I loved
the two of them together their
personalities like Kim making fun of
herself for losing in the Instagram
follower contest also Kylie is setting
spray like not working oh hey Larry
hilarious and I mean oh and then and
then Kim also being like oh wow this is
do I'm a copy of for k'kaw beauty
no they're hilarious yeah it's actually
so interesting to see them together
because because we never see Kylie you
kind of forget that she like radiates
personality she's so funny and like
charismatic and you just never hear from
her and you only see pictures of her
like looking fatty and you forget that
there's like a girl behind the thought
there really is and we love that girl we
love her I saw that the video I could
have gone for it to be so much longer
and it was distracting because they did
QA on top of the makeup tutorial and I
wanted to hear about what Kylie was
doing you're only showing their own
products no I don't care about use your
own products but like I
want to hear about your steps yeah like
is it a makeup tutorial or is it a Q&A
can we get two videos like I I want to
see how she does brows how she does
contour like she was just glazing over
the makeup and answering questions like
hoodie could have been sitting it was
just too much [ __ ] going on and I
couldn't tell if Kim was reading the
questions off of her phone or just
texting the whole time Kim is always oh
she was working on her phone yes she was
doing three things she was doing Q&A
makeup tutorial and tech and on the
phone with her eight of her lawyers
right doing seven business deals with
her attorney yeah exactly
it was a good video I just loved Kylie
content she has that whole studio why
doesn't she release it more often for
sure but the Christmas cookies content
like was not it for me not at all
like sometimes she just tries to put her
hand in every genre like beauty baking
like just stick to what you know yeah
yeah thought land you know just stick to
that pink background and like doing
makeup your makeup sisters just like
show how it's done I could watch her do
her makeup her everyday makeup everyday
me too and just talk about it yeah she's
really good at makeup and when she said
like if I wasn't doing what I would if I
wasn't Kylie Jenner I would be a makeup
artist like I actually believed her a
hundred percent you could tell she
really loves the makeup and that's why
Kylie cosmetics is so successful because
it's like from a fan to the thing yes so
anyways I loved the video that's why I
like all makeup like huge makeup brands
the the people who it's named after like
we're always started off as makeup
artists like Laura Mercier like yeah
Kylie really is like an icon in the
making uh Nastasia like she does
Charlotte Tilbury
she's like a makeup like she at least
she'll be like at UM like it was like
the most famous it's hard because all
these brands like come and go but like
her Kylie cosmetics will be like a
lasting brand and they say Lauder right
yes thank you yeah also you saw the Chi
trademarked Kylie con and like Museum of
Kylie very cool love it I will be
attending Ayanna I will be requesting a
press pass yeah and I will definitely be
going to the Museum of Kylie for sure
but I can also just go for a Museum of
Kardashians I think that would be like
even better um okay yeah I'm okay okay
let's get into the first story because a
little piggybacking off of a story
yesterday Olivia culpo is defending her
BFF Cara Santana
I made her break up with Jesse met
confirming any speculation that they are
not in an open relationship and Cara
Santana is in fact upset yes at 100% we
try to give the benefit of the doubt we
did so Olivia culpo first posted don't
cheat nobody likes a cheater
and then another story that says when
someone upsets my best friend and it is
McAllister with a shotgun and she added
Cara Santana so I think we know how she
feels
yeah it wasn't you know subtlety is in
her strong suit
and it's not mine you know it's not
yours so I totally understand I just I
have to assume she got approval a
hundred percent and I actually loved
their way I'm coming about this cuz it's
like Cara doesn't have to say anything
Olivia can be like the bad guy even
though like we were also here for it and
Jesse Metcalfe is the bad guy and it's
like we know how you guys feel and maybe
they are tired of like seeing
speculation like he's were they together
is it over they should have been like
thank you for just letting us know the
fact no any more celebrities we just be
this director with us so outright no
statement from a publicist just like
true communication and that's all we can
ask for as a fan and as far as John
Tucker goes shame on you shame on you
for ruining a 13-year relationship no
and shame on you for ruining all these
double dates like all the fun you were
having you were going to the Superbowl
you were on boats that you're in the
Bahamas and you know what that's all
over for you and you can go back to the
Hallmark Channel no it's so true I can
go shave your back now because when I
first heard about their relationship I'm
like Oh Jesse McAuliffe is a certified
celebrity and I don't know who Cara
Santana is he is kind of dating someone
less famous than him but then the more
we got to know them like she was the one
who's so connected and doing so well
with the glam up and she was the one
becoming friends Olivia culpo and
getting them all on the boat with Devin
Windsor like he was she was really like
the social events coordinator of the
relationship and she made him cool he
went to the Super Bowl because of her
yeah it's like now you're gonna bite the
hand that feeds you no Candice antenna
deserves a man who appreciates all of
her connections yes I would appreciate
that by the way I do appreciate that
might end they give us yet no I would
appreciate them like if I were him you
know I would do everything to make it
work of course any time I'm so
appreciative but not be seen with like
models in the street no and by the way
that's what's so horrible about this
whole thing and really reminds me of the
Justin Timberlake thing it's not even
like you got a camera in someone's hotel
room it's like you're out in public I
send him really can Jessica be aware in
my dream last night and they were being
so nice to me and I just felt awful
about the things that I had said oh my
god do you think it's a song I just want
to take back anything I ever said about
that I don't think you really said I
think I've said he's a talentless hack
but that wasn't what I was talking about
I stand by that fact I
said about their relationship you know I
don't what did I say I don't even know
we're just talking about the yeah no it
wasn't good we didn't say anything bad
yes but the hand-holding and the tie
well speaking of dreams I did not have a
nightmare about the beacon last night
love it only like two more sleeps three
right Thursday night Friday night that's
it two more sleeps two more sleeps oh my
god I've been seething so soundly I
wonder why I'm so nervous you guys like
I just I can't stress enough if you're
gonna be there just like laughs so hard
no no it laughs so hard at everything
like if I say like ah you go yeah like I
just need cackles because this cannot
flop it just can't yeah yeah well could
and I just have to say and I don't want
to you know I'm not gonna say whoa I was
just gonna jinx myself oh my god um we
got you we will come through with the
laughter don't worry
we will bring a laugh track it'll be
just like friends okay you guys in the
best news I've heard all week Channing
Tatum and Jessie J are reportedly back
together two months after their split
thank God honestly this this split made
note you know what's so funny there the
relationship of not making sense because
when they got together it made no sense
and then when they broke up it made no
sense no but then being back together
makes all the sense in the right no I I
believe in their love for sure to me
they are a perfect match like and now
that they've broken up and they went
through the process of announcing it
like it makes me it puts a stain on
their relationship for sure um but I
just love these two I I really champion
them as a couple I believe in their love
and I'm excited for their future I hope
that they you know are making plans yeah
yeah and also Jenna and Juan is like so
happy pregnant because he was yeah Steve
his name of like Machens wedding planner
stevesie his name reminds me of a
cassette it's Steve Cassetti Steve
Kazaam
stop wait let's figure it out Steve's I
cam Jenna Dewan meaning I'm Twilight
Steve Kazee see the oh yeah like a kazoo
that's what you were thinking about that
oh yeah but a kazoo is like that
mouthing like me yes yes Steve Kazee
Steve Kazee yeah she's happy chanting
deserves to be I really ship him and
seems like he's really supportive of her
I can't explain now I'm always reading
articles
I'm going to her shows and you know is
she the greatest you know pop star in
the world no but yes well the answer to
that is yes 22 us yes but according to
the mainstream media no so he just
really believes in her and I believe in
them and I'm really excited about what
the future has in store for them
me too okay do you want to say something
about the future I mean the future is so
uncertain and I think what's certain is
the uncertainty but with hellofresh I'm
certain that I'm gonna be getting great
meals with pre measured ingredients
delivered right to my door it's
America's number one meal kit making
cooking at home fun easy and most
importantly affordable break out of your
dinner rut with hellofresh is 22 plus
seasonal delicious chef curate recipes
every week there's something for
everyone including low calorie
vegetarian and family friendly recipes
hellofresh has more five-star recipes
than any other meal kit so you know
you'll get something delicious you
didn't save time and stress they cut out
stressful meal planning and meal
prepping so you can enjoy cooking and
get dinner on the table in just 30
minutes or even 20 minutes with with
their quick recipe options the average
trip to the grocery store takes 41
minutes
that's over 35 hours a year if you go
once a week and then not to count you
know all the stress of the dishes that
you're never gonna do just stick with
how fresh they make it so easy and they
help you eat more sustainably there
pre-portioned ingredients mean there's
less prep for you and less food waste
the packaging hellofresh uses to ship
your food is almost entirely made of
recyclable and or recycled content hello
fresh is carbon footprint is 25 percent
lower than any star bar cross grocery
meals face oh my god stop and you can
add extra meals or lunches to your
weekly order or throw in yummy sides and
desserts like garlic bread and cookie
dough easily change your delivery days
or food preferences or skip a week
whenever you need hellofresh is now five
dollars and sixty six cents per serving
and we highly encourage you to check it
out it's America's number one meal kit
we've had a little offer for you if
you're feeling like you want to eat
sustainably eat well and get your New
Year's resolutions on track go to hello
fresh comm slash toast ten and use the
code toast ten during hello freshers New
Year's sale for ten free meals including
free shipping so that's hello fresh comm
slash toast one zero and the code is
toast one zero during hello freshest New
Year's sale ten meals
including free shipping check it out
sign on eat well I just got my meals
from hellofresh for the week and they're
so good it makes me so excited to cook
and it's the perfect like I'm a chef
with hellofresh like I'm a bonafide cook
and you can't tell me otherwise because
I'm making enchiladas in the home do you
think you are more or less qualified as
a chef than Chef Boyardee oh I guess
less cuz he has like a whole brand and
style these days have you ever had Chef
Boyardee I'm sure I haven't and I feel
like I would love it my pasta in a can
sign me up
okay are you ready for our next story
because Jessica Simpson's men Mar is
making headlines again oh my queen and I
think your your queen and your king are
part of this story before we did your
pink Joe Jonas no your other done there
yeah oh my god by the way I can't
believe that was ever like a point in my
life where I was alive where John Mayer
and Jessica Simpson we're together and I
wasn't like old enough to start creating
it but oh my god and when he says on her
and that Rolling Stone article I know
like it's considered misogynistic actual
napalm yeah that she was the best sex I
ever had and like you can't get enough
her like I know that was considered and
I'm such an estate but like I'm here for
it well she's talking about how she felt
about that oh my god your relationship
oh wait really quickly before we jump in
we were talking about birthday buddies
yesterday we didn't scroll down on my
birthday page enough to realize that
Gary livox the lead singer of Rascal
Flatts is also my birthday buddy so I
just wanted to put that out there that's
major major okay
Jessica Simpson's memoir reveals John
Mayer said he was obsessed with her and
how she feels about his sexual napalm
comment in her upcoming memoir open book
she writes candidly about what she
learned about herself from her
relationships including her romance with
musician John Mayer I gotta read this
book I've got to read this book they met
in early 2005 at a Grammy party thrown
by Clive Davis the guitarist told her
how much he admired a song she wrote
called with you and she was flattered
when he began to write the note he
started writing her the notes quickly
became more intimate and after she
divorced Nick Lachey in late 2005 she
began dating other men but as she writes
mayor told her he wanted to have quote
all of me or nothing quotes walk into a
room and pick up his guitar and you'd
swoon I didn't really know the man
behind the guitar and that was my
mission they dated in secret for several
months and she fell in love with his
intensity quote again and again he told
me
was obsessed with me sexually and
emotionally while mayor made her feel
powerful physically she also felt
insecure around him feeling like she
always had to win him over after many
after one of their many breakups
although she prided herself on not being
the dumb blonde as she was often
portrayed she began to have self doubts
quote I was constantly worried that I
wasn't smart enough for him he was so
clever and treated conversation like a
friendly competition that he had to win
those people I know them there so no I
just say like not to always make
everything about Taylor Swift but it
really sounds like what she's describing
is what Taylor Swift wrote about in Dear
John like like some of the lyrics are
just minding me of it like it's that
competition and like dishes a line about
playing chess it's like everything is a
move yeah Wow I feel like this is really
gonna break John Mayer's heart because
he used to be like so nuts but he's
really like awoke like recovering he
calls himself womanizer
and he's so like you know sensitive now
that I feel like just this coming up
again and like realizing the damage that
he caused like a young woman I feel like
it's really gonna upset him I talk about
him like I know him intimately and I do
yeah she talks about him calling her
sexual napalm in a 2010 Playboy
interview quote he thought that that was
what I wanted to be called she says I
was floored and embarrassed that my
grandmother was actually gonna read that
a woman and how they are in bed is not
something that has ever talked about it
was shocking I understand that that's so
invasive
but like you can call me that job I'm
glad they're on the other side of it I
agree like we didn't appreciate what we
had when we had it on this book sounds
so good so good and she's not holding
back anything you know I feel like she
was really quiet about like a lot of the
Hollywood stuff that like happened to
her and that she saw when she was at
such a young age and now she's at the
point in her life or like she's married
she has kids she's happy she's got a
billion-dollar business she's got a
plane she's telling the spilling yes she
has nothing to hide it said once you
have a plane you could say whatever you
want kid look at Diplo right I think
both of our examples Kid Rock
okay our next story is like really crazy
I think but not surprising because James
Corden doesn't Drive during car pee
carpool karaoke and fans are shook so a
Twitter user posted a video of what
appeared to be James Corden riding
around with Justin Bieber for a reported
upcoming episode however one thing in
particular caught band's attention The
Late Late Show host wasn't actually
driving in fact
the car was being pulled by a truck hey
so I've actually always wondered this
but James does such a good job of like
really turning as the car is turning
that I believe or treats the turns into
his moves right and sometimes on shows
that are in cars like comedians and cars
you can always see when they're filming
the car from the front there's always a
minivan behind Jerry Seinfeld's car and
that's like production it's always the
same minivan suppose if you get these
little hints and I've always looked for
that in um James Corden I've never seen
him like to him I guess they really just
put up some GoPros and let him do his
thing ya know it makes sense cuz it's
probably not safe to like right yeah
doing an interview talking dancing
singing while driving so and by the way
they need equipment they need monitors
like there's nowhere to put it yeah so
I'm glad for everyone that this is the
case but it's crazy that we didn't know
this until now the show's been like
happening for a few years and no one's
seen this right and so many people they
went so many episodes they rolled down
the windows take pictures with people
like no video has ever gone viral before
this it's honestly shocking these are
huge stars in there like one direction
and they always stop and like hang with
the fans yes this sleeve almost went to
McDonald's how did the trolley pull him
in I think the Charlie could drive
through it's like a tow truck yeah but
then it's like the trolley has to go and
then James Corden is pulling like it's
honestly if he did sure if the trolley
turns in correctly James Corden could
end up inside the machine maybe for
those sorts of things they did get dry
yeah I don't know but this is bodes well
for me because if I ever got James
Corden job like I wouldn't need to learn
how to drive I hope they address it in
some way because it did go so viral like
now it's funny like now we're just
watching him fake turn the car yeah
maybe I got that and he puts his
blinkers on he's weirdly playing the
part looking in his rearview yeah no I
appreciate the craft actually don't want
him to stop like let us let the dream
continue well I'm excited part of this
news that were totally glossing over is
that Justin Bieber's doing carpool
karaoke I know I don't I don't know I
don't like live breathe and die for
Justin Bieber but I live breathing die
for carpool karaoke and if anything is
gonna like make me fall in love with
Justin Bieber like it might just be
carpool carpool karaoke has a way of
changing people for me yeah so it's kind
of like watch happens live if someone
comes on watch happens live whoo I don't
like live for but they like get involved
and they like love Bravo it makes me
always like them yeah for sure but now
like
Billy Eilish because of carpool karaoke
like I sent OKC yes I'd like to see you
before but her carpool karaoke was so
stellar hmm such a talent what a star
really took my stand hood - and I had
then Taylor done carpool karaoke I don't
know can you ask her when you talk a lot
of people thought we were gonna get it
with a leather no with the cats promo at
least he had so I really thought it was
coming then I don't know has Beyonce
done it no no Gaga has Katy Perry has
selena has Adele has Adele has maybe
she'll do promo for her documentary then
I don't know she has a lot of stuff
coming up so like it's possible but I
wonder if there's any know she's good
friends of James Corden I don't know
they did and she did Late Late Night 4
promo of cats they did like some segment
about her like licking milk from a bowl
like she was there she was in the studio
why don't you just get in the car that
would be so iconic I didn't she get in
the tow truck why did she get in the
trolley I don't know but are you ready
for the final story so soon um am i I
don't know that you are it's a little
bit of not business news tech news well
I love technique it's only appropriate
that I highlight one of my favorite tech
companies and it's actually Theo's
favorite tech company whether you have a
new pup or an old friend an embarked
breed and health test is the key to
unlocking your dog's unique breed mix
and genetically informed health needs so
you can help your pup libbets healthiest
happiest life finally get to know your
pup every year millions of dogs are
rescued from shelters well we know we
love them there's a lot that we don't
know about them and with an embark DNA
test you can finally have an answer the
next time someone stops you with that
how cute how what kind of dog is it I
didn't I for Theo it was so easy you
basically put the little q-tip in their
little cheek pocket get some saliva put
it back in the tube they send you a
prepaid label you ship it out and then
like a couple weeks later you got a text
your embark results are ready and it was
really shocking to everyone that Theo
was 3% wolf enos of course but you know
what he is he just took a DNA test
turns out he's a hundred percent Russian
even when he's fleeing countries yeah he
got health problems that's the puppy in
in bling bling then he saw him got the
doctor and you could have had a bag
Diggs
Massimo helped you with your welfare
just a little
okay I got an ad to do that is the ad
you guys if you want to write a rap
about your song your dog's origins and
Mark the embark DNA test helps you know
it helps you screen for a hundred and
seventy plus genetic health conditions
and they help your vet provide the best
medical care for your dog if you're
looking to improve your dog's quality of
life you can learn their ancestry back
to great-grandparents meet their
relatives discover other dogs with
similar breed mixes embark is the only
dog DNA test that performs research
great DNA testing this allows our
veterinary and research teams to conduct
groundbreaking research to extend the
lives of all their dogs it's the most
comprehensive kit on the market market
looking at over two hundred fifty dog
breeds and one hundred and seventy
genetic health conditions to help you
best care for your breed it's the best
in class the best in class dog DNA test
number one highest rated by customers
and it's developed by PhDs and
veterinarians for your dog it's a great
thing if you have a dog it's a great
gift for someone who's obsessed with
their dog like if somebody had gotten
specific as a gift it actually would
have been so so special but I got afraid
because they sponsor the show but check
it out it's really it's such a great
thing and I really love it they have an
exclusive offer for our toasters and you
can't get it anywhere else so make sure
you listen go to embark vet calm now the
promo code is toast to save 15% off your
dog DNA test kit so it's EMBA RK v ET
comm promo code toast for 15% off your
dog DNA test kit embark vet comm promo
code toast to save sign on write a song
about your dog I can't say I'm saving my
vocals yeah it's been - story
Motorola's foldable razor will launch on
February 6th after delay have you heard
about this phone no it is a phone that
looks like an Android oh but it
collapses it's a new flip phone you guys
and I don't know that I would ever like
switch from an iPhone but if I was ever
going to this is it like I need a flip
phone in my leg I mean there's nothing
like slamming the phone down when you're
angry like just tapping the end button
is not saying you know I need to click
you off but I'm worried because I have a
lot of energy and a lot of power and I
feel like I would just say phone down
like to hang up on someone and it might
crack the glass no no way this is
definitely made of the best stuff in the
biz and look how tiny it is when you
fold it up so try
which Apple would make a flip phone yeah
maybe day well because they're always
copying things other people don't feel
like you should just get like an old
flip phone and just take my calls from
it okay I just want to say I ordered an
old Blackberry on Amazon or yeah Amazon
because I wanted to be like Kim
Kardashian who like used to use
blackberry for her emails and it came
and like it was so hard to use my
fingers are huge I don't remember how we
ever used to do it yeah and it was like
you can't even get your email on there
without internet cuz you know it was
just so confusing yeah that's really
confusing
they still make blackberries um no I
think the company that made them like
went bankrupt but Kim gets hers on eBay
I'm really like happy for the kids of
today that they have tick-tock but
they'll never know like the BBM life and
I truly feel sorry for them no the BDM
life was the best life if you know your
PIN my heart yeah thank you for always
getting a new PIN right cuz got a new
phone yeah and then it's like if you're
writing like new PIN like oh you got a
new phone like cool for you I'm like
someone would take your bbm and like
make your status something crazy you
know yeah those were the days honestly
bbm life was so lit and then there was
all these hacks to like read someone's
without having it say are o true yeah
those were exciting yeah I feel like
many a relationship are really
cultivated and started on bbm those were
the days you guys but enjoy any of our
young toaster it stands for blackberry
messenger which is basically like
iMessage for people with blackberries
yeah but now they have like snapchat
that's what they use what we saw so Sam
I don't know it's pretty fun like azm
was so iconic I see the love snapchat
yeah well she's out of control so she's
so out of control tell me more about
this phone how much is it gonna cost
fifteen hundred dollars to order
starting January 26 what do you that's
like what you paid for your phone for an
iPhone yeah no but this is like a full
Android which you know people like that
who say is better and it's a flip phone
like that's the cost of a phone that's
and this is the highest technology that
like is a screen that's like your iPhone
screen that you're able to flip it it's
just kind of crazy yeah I mean I'm here
for it I'm here for it I would love
someone to get it I just want to play
with it because I'm obviously not really
gonna make the switch but yeah maybe we
should like get one for the biz oh
that's a good idea
and just like play games on it yeah and
MIT take calls and just be like I'm
sorry yeah no it's just there's nothing
that compares to doing that it's like no
or like when you were getting a manicure
and you're like oh yeah
like open a few and you were like
actually six years old yeah mom I'll be
right up no like and that's my movies
like the click and things like that are
so iconic because of like the little
phone charm it's the power of the flick
code it's such a different and that's
even um you know that episode of Sex in
the City when Samantha's planning that
millionaires daughters bum it's though
yeah I heard her fridge like so [ __ ]
and there were you Chi bags and they
have sex and get [ __ ] in the hip
flip phones
yeah actually someone's phone rings and
then it's it's actually played by kat
dennings she takes the phone and let you
open so flip phone like that wouldn't
have been as iconic of a scene no and it
wouldn't if she was just sliding to the
right not the same not the same as I why
do you agree
oh my god we need to get one on eBay and
like make it kind of I'll get like a
number and that'll be like my work phone
that framework calls or like you know
they still sell those like fake kid
phones in flip phone versions like at
Walmart oh yeah it's me I got oh way
that's so funny okay do with anything
else Jackie didn't watch Real Housewives
of New Jersey I did and I would recap it
without you but I have a lot of thoughts
and I read Brian Moylan some recap and
he really made a very interesting point
okay could we could it wait till
tomorrow because I will watch the
episode for tomorrow I just I had to
finish my book and I thought that the
toaster is like would give me a pass for
it I know I mean I had a full show last
night and I watched it this morning but
dude dude I also have two episodes to
watch that's what I like was when I miss
one and I we didn't talk about it last
week I love to watch like when I can
walk that's how I would watch them if I
didn't do this show like I love to watch
a few together it just makes it like you
don't see what those click cliffhangers
so let me I won't put anything in your
mind it was just like a hard a pisode to
watch because you know i see on jennifer
so much and she was like kind of wrong
okay % but kind of keep that in mind
alright well we have one more toast till
begin which is so crazy it will be at
12:30 tomorrow because like some of us
just have to sleep in for for our sister
for my boys yeah I just don't want to
lose my boys and tonight it's gonna be a
crazy night in Inglewood so I'm excited
to see all the toasters there thank you
guys so much for listening to the
morning toast millennium morning trouble
we go live Monday through Friday 10:30
a.m. Eastern Time on YouTube so if
you're watching us on YouTube please
feel free to swipe up subscribe you know
all the things we're also available as a
podcast pretty much anywhere podcasts
can be found so that's Spotify iTunes
stitcher Public Radio I already know
Katz box all the places so wherever you
choose to listen to podcasts leave a
review find
the morning shows five stars about how
beautiful stunning and smart we are we
love you guys so much have an amazing
day we will see you tomorrow at 12:30
Eastern Time have a good one